bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois une historienne
ludivine bantigny pour son livre la plus
belle avenue du monde c'est un essai sur
les champs elysées en tant qu'enjeu de
pouvoir ait lieu de confrontation des
classes sociales et pas seulement depuis
le mouvement des gilet jaune comme vous
allez voir ça a toujours été comme ça je
reçois également une romancière les à
simone alegria qui publie le grand art
ou comment tu as un peintre de génie
peut naître six siècles après sa mort
est une scénariste de bande dessinée que
thil de bono pour mal tourné illustré
par isa python sur une jeune femme qui
voit du sexe partout une métaphore sans
doute de notre époque totalement
pornographiques et l'on commence comme
d'habitude par cette époque que nous
sommes en train de vivre qu'est ce qui
la caractérise voici vos réponses en
images on commence par la vôtre léa
simone alegria ça ressemble à un
caravage c'est un caravage salut savoir
c'est un tabou qui s'appelle le
reniement de saint pierre qui datent de
1610 et qui est conservé au met
alors oui j'ai choisi une oeuvre qu'à
400 ans pour pour parler de notre époque
ben je pense que c'est la force d'un
chef-d'oeuvre ces deux
c'est de glisser sur le temps et d'être
toujours toujours actuel est toujours
contemporaine alors dans cette oeuvre si
on si on oublie que ça s'appelle le
reniement de saint pierre et qu' on ne
sait pas que c'est un récit biblique et
qu'on voit juste trois personnages on
peut dire que qu'on est tout de suite
attrapé par par un sentiment de menace
qui pèse un peu sur sur ses personnages
donc il ya un soldat une femme et un
vieillard et on sent qu'il ya une
urgence qui est quelque chose qui est en
train de se passer est en fait tout et
toute l'action et est dit par les mains
des personnages il ya le soldat qui
s'apprête à pointer le vieillard
mais il ne pointe pas encore tout à fait
donc là c'est le couperet qui va qui
va-t-on ses traits caravage adeptes dans
un instant voilà c'est un moment très
particulier
pommier pathographie qu'on fait plus
avec le cadrage à mi corps comme ça
qu'ils rentrent dans la seine et et ont
saisi le personnage il ya la femme qui
pointe déjà
et il ya le vieillard qui se pointe
lui-même qui se désigne lui-même et qui
a l'air de dire quoi moi non mais et
c'est pour moi la force de ce tableau et
la puissance de caravage c'est que c'est
qu'en fait il nous met mal à l'aise nous
en tant que spectateur inouïe nous
déstabilise parce qu'ils nous invitent à
participer à une dénonciation un
jugement alors que
alors qu'on voit on voit pas la scène du
crime on voit aussi dégraisser on n'en
sait rien il n'y a pas de décors rien
pour nous indiquer exactement de quoi il
est coupable et donc il ya un peu ce
côté vous de voyeurisme avec cette femme
qui est qui est jeté dans la lumière et
et ce devoir de juger quelque chose dont
tu entends ton de série dont on ne sait
rien ces traits de notre époque
voilà c'est ça pour moi ça
représentative et notre divine
bantignies annoncée celle de clotilde
sept hauts en couleur exactement et
c'est la remise des prix du festival de
bd d'angoulême festivals d'europe de
chine et du monde voilà bien évidemment
rien n'a pas d'autres le premier qui a
été créé en tout cas devrait-il vieux
en effet il jouit d'une certaine
réputation internationale et nationale
beaucoup et cette année en fait non je
regrettais beaucoup de pas pouvoir y
être mais cette année va les collègues
sont montés sur scène pour essayer de se
faire entendre comme beaucoup de je
pense de corps de métier depuis quelques
temps et moi cette cette image en fait
ne fait plus l acheter une chambre au
visage avec une page blanche
parce qu'en fait il ya une question de
comment les artistes réussissent à se
faire entendre aujourd'hui dans un temps
de protestation au delà de leurs oeuvres
en fait en tant que corps de métier les
auteurs particulièrement parce que
finalement notre seule arme en quelque
sorte ça va être de crayon ça va être de
pouvoir faire un dessin éventuellement
ou d'écrire quelque chose mais quand
l'urgence et arrive en fait qu'est ce
qu'on fait et c'est une question qu'on
continue à se poser nous en tant
qu'auteur en train de se dire bon bah on
a un rapport qui est tombée juste avant
ghoulem le rapport à sin qui doit
apporter normalement quelques on espère
quelques réponses nombreuses
interrogations qu'on a quand à notre
statut à notre précarité
mais angoulême est en passe et emmanuel
macron est on venu serrer des mains et
et visiter un petit peu les expositions
maintenant que les médias ne parlent
plus trop finalement de la bd et puis un
petit peu de manière plus générale des
artistes auteurs et que le salon du
livre est annulé il y à une question de
finalement ou est ce que les artistes et
où est ce que les auteurs vont pouvoir
manifester ou essayer de se faire
entendre et je n'ai pas encore de
réponse à cette enquête en cours depuis
rassemblement de plus de 1000 personnes
exactement très clairement donc
finalement cette image pour moi c'est
plus une question qui plus que d'eux
mêmes de notre époque est vraiment
quasiment la question de la semaine de
commandes at on faire pour se faire
entendre quand déjà
on est un petit peu inaudible en tant
qu'artiste mais alors en plus qu'en
maintenant le corps est d'être virginie
manifester n'ayant plus à l'est en salon
pour s'exprimer
ludivine menti me voilà une image de
manifester voilà alors c'est une
photographie de serge d'ignazio je tiens
vraiment à signaler son travail et c'est
d'ailleurs voir non pas d'image de lui
puisqu'il adore en effet c'est un ancien
ouvrier qui photographient toutes les
manifestations enfin il est présent
vraiment partout dans le mouvement
social là où il ya de la lutte là où les
gens se soulèvent pour s'exprimer pour
revendiquer et en fait aspirer aussi à
une société un peu un peu plus juste un
peu plus humaine alors c'est pas tout à
fait cette société juste et humaine dont
témoigne cette photographie de serge
ignazio qui a été prise en décembre 2018
sur les champs elysées donc devant la
boutique cartier fermé comme vous le
voyez par son rideau de fer en fait
cette photo elle me fait penser à ce que
raconte le philosophe allemand valter
benyamine qui parle du pouvoir en tant
qu il a trois armes le sang dutil le
sens c'est-à-dire la police à ses yeux
la ruse à savoir la mode
et puis la magie à savoir le faste et il
m'a semblé que en fait cette
photographie elle rassemblait un peu ces
trois ingrédients qui sont un peu à
l'image des champs elysées dont il
s'agit de parler dans le lit
cette espèce de vertige abyssales ces
écarts considérables
une sorte de concentré justement du
monde tel qu'il est tel qu'il est tel
qu'il ait disputé tel qu'il est contesté
aussi comme l'ont fait les gilet jaune
justement en s'emparant des champs
elysées en répondant évidemment à ce
qu'avait suggéré emmanuel macron qu'il
vienne me chercher donc ce que ça
signifie voilà d'aller le chercher
voilà on vient te chercher chez toi
comme le disent les gilet jaune qu'est
ce que ça signifie prendre les champs
elysées et qu'est ce que ça signifie
aussi que cet ordre des forces de
l'ordre quel ordre protège les forces de
l'ordre et cette photo me semble assez
symbolique de voilà de cet ordre social
économique et politique qu'elle protège
à certains égards et bien commençons
[Musique]
ludivine bantigny vous publiez donc la
plus belle avenue du monde aux éditions
de la découverte une histoire sociale et
politique que vous avez vous commencé
votre livre le 16 mars 2019 avec le
fouquet's vandalisés par les gilet jaune
voici une photo toujours de serge milhas
you d'ailleurs telle qu'elle figure dans
votre livre
alors pourquoi ce 16 mars 2010neuf parce
que les gilet jaune sur les
champs-elysées sa date de novembre 2018
probablement d'ailleurs le
retentissement que ça a pu avoir
pas seulement en france mais dans le
monde entier
c'est sans doute lié au fait que ça se
déroulait sur les champs elysées
justement à pain toute la première
partie du mouvement s'est concentré sur
les champs elysées les images font le
tour du monde et on voit des images
hallucinantes on enverra au cours de
cette émission on a eu une année eu
beaucoup sur cette chaîne non mais c'est
important que des médias aient pu
relayer ce soulèvement populaire
autrement que par la disqualification
par le dénigrement
c'est vrai qu'avec rémy toulouse
l'éditeur à la découverte qui m'a
proposé ce projet de livre non c'est pas
à mon idée mais je les trouvais
finalement très très passionnante et en
écho à un travail que je mène depuis
plusieurs années sur l'histoire sociale
et politique sur les mouvements sociaux
sur les insurrections les rébellions et
aussi les conditions de travail la
vallasse cette symbolique tellement
incroyable d'une avenue un peu de cartes
postales qui à la fois facile et un
objet de fascination et aussi à un
repoussoir à certains métiers etc et
l'avenue la plus célèbre du monde 2
oui c'est la venue voilà et donc moi je
tenais beaucoup aux guillemets pour le
titre de l'ouvragé la plus belle avenue
du monde puisqu'il s'agit évidemment de
l'explorer un peu à contretemps à
contre-jour dans une certaine mesure
et voilà ce fouquet's en flammes dont on
peut souligner derrière que les chefs
halal incendie n'a pas été provoquée par
les manifestants eux-mêmes enfin en tout
cas il ya l'hypothèse est là selon
laquelle ce serait un palais de gaz
lacrymogènes a ajouté par les forces de
l'ordre lors des tensions et des
affrontements
mais voilà ccc finalement l'emblème en
une sorte de métaphore de cet
affrontement de deux classes sociales en
fait de cet affrontement social à vif
comme ça écueil est ce finalement ce
courage d'aller sur les champs-elysées
samedi après samedi malgré l'importance
de la répression face à témoigner aussi
de la manière dont les gilets jaunes ont
modifié le rapport aux lieux en fait au
lieu sociaux au lieu politique par
exemple ils ont fait des ronds points
qui est qui sont des lieux sans âme des
lieux de pure circulation vide de sens
justement mais ils lui ont donné un sens
autrement que giratoire et la randonnée
l'idée que ça pouvait être des lieux
comme un vrai bon donc ces jeux légers
tels sur les champs-elysées justement
alors on a fabriqué du prestige dites
vous
à propos de cette avenue on en a fait un
espace bourgeois et aristocratique et
pourtant il est pas homogène il est pas
sans aspérité et ça a toujours été un
lieu de mélange des groupes sociaux et
au fond c'est un condensé pour vous des
rapports sociaux exactement enfin pour
moi c'est vraiment une manière de
prendre un espace en tant qu il est
social pour réfléchir au monde justement
actuelle et aussi du point de vue
historique parce que comme vous le
soulignez à juste titre en fait depuis
que louis xiv a ordonné justement
l'ouverture de ceux de secours de cette
allée 784 tôt à la pomme c'est la
première hausse et en 594 con con en
tout cas qu'on l'appelle champs elysées
voilà parce que ça doit être un espace
mythique qui rappelle le paradis des
anciens ce tissage et celle des radis
des grecs
voilà exactement donc de paradis des
âmes vertueuses et c est ce qui est très
très fascinant c'est que jusqu'aux
années 1840 environ ça reste un espace
aussi champêtre c'est un espace de
mélange des espaces urbains et un bout
de campagne où il ya encore des
troupeaux qui pèse 7 c et où le pouvoir
a un objectif c'est d'éradiquer tout ce
qui peut encore être populaire sur cet
espace
parce que c'est c'est fin c'est une
histoire de voilà deux nobiliaire et de
populaire en effet et depuis les
origines parce que c'est un espace que
toute la cour fréquentent donc c'est un
lieu hautement aristocratique
mais c'est aussi un lieu où il ya des
mazures des fermes
c'est une voie royale puisque c'est
entre le château de versailles et le
château des tuileries tu as fait d un
sceptre brandi cannes c'est vers là mais
c'est peu praticables c'est mal famé et
en même temps c'est s'est fréquenté par
les gens bien nés tout comme parler sans
asile dit
les coupeurs de bourse il ya une crainte
d'une gravure que l'on voit là où ils 16
qui arpentent les champs elysées de
l'époque du recrutement
il ya des hommes est qui et qui
rencontre justement un balayeur ne l'est
pas car moi j'ai rencontré les balayeurs
des champs elysées aujourd'hui mais
voilà cette gravure ben je vous remercie
de l'avoir choisie parce qu'elle avait
retenu parce que mais elle elle est
aussi la métaphore de ces écarts
incroyable et en effet de cette
construction politique de l'avenue
comment le pouvoir a décidé de faire de
cet espace un emblème de sa puissance
comme le fait également napoléon 1er en
décidant de la construction de combat
noire il est là vous montrez bien que le
tournant c'est la révolution française
c'est à partir de la révolution que ça
se politise en fait exactement parce que
là la rencontre avec le balayeur le
bailleur ne sais même pas qui l'a fait
roi
mais à partir de la révolution ça
devient un vrai terrain de confrontation
des isles et c'est intéressant ce que
vous dites sur le fait que le balayeur
ne sait pas qu'il a affaire au roi on a
les archives d'un commissaire préposé à
la surveillance des champs elysées entre
les années 1770 et 1790 et au début de
la révolution française c'est comme s'il
ne se passait rien autour de lui lui il
continue à être obsédé par
les partis c'est un voile a donné partie
de sexe qui se joue à l époque il ya
beaucoup de prostitution donc mais une
traque
il traque en particulier l'homosexualité
comme un péché à lui dans les bus sont
des champs-elysées mais c'est vrai que
pendant la révolution et en particulier
en juillet 1792 les fédérés marseillais
sont invités en grande pompe lors d'un
banquet sur les champs elysées et une
partie de la garde nationale rester
fidèle au roi les attaques il ya un
massacre et donc on peut dire finalement
que c'est sur les champs elysées comme
au champ-de-mars quelques quelques
semaines auparavant que se joue la mise
à bas de l'ancien régime alors dans
l'espace devient en effet un espace
aussi révélé j'ai ça dans l'espace peut
habiter il ya une autre gravure qui
montre une petite le genre de mesure qui
avait en fin de match et une maison en
ruine une bonne maison petite faire
c'est offenser c'est soulant pire qu'on
va en faire un lieu prestigieux et vous
le disiez ça commence avec le mariage de
napoléon avec marie-louise oui en 1810
avec l'arc de triomphe qui est dressé là
qu'il a fallu finir à toute allure et il
était à terre il est d'ailleurs des
grèves sa il ya déjà eu lieu pour
fondation voilà formidable comme un peu
plus tard sur chantier la tour eiffel
donc voilà cet espace de confiture alité
social en effet et puis de pouvoir au
sens où il s'agit de l'occuper à toute
force
il ya des trucs d'occuper voilà c'est ce
qu'on va voir c'est que dès l'instant où
les alliés arrivé en 1814 les revue de
troupes sur les champs-elysées les
cosaques bivouac sur les champs-elysées
la sueur des russes 1 en 1814 et ça
commence et ça va plus s'arrêter on
al'impression 1 puisque ensuite 1870 les
prussiens battent les faits où est ce
qu'ils vont faire
ils vont sur les champs-elysées en 19 en
la grande victoire le défilé de la
victoire à la fin dans le premier on le
ferait mais défilé militaire en fait
véritablement sur les sur les champs
elysées et la manière dont on érige cet
espace aussi en un monument honore
nationale voilà et ce sera ensuite les
allemands qui défilent en 48 la cette
photo date de 1942 quand de gaulle
arrive libération de paris sur les
champs-elysées bien entendu ça ne
s'arrête jamais c'est
c'est d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de
juxtaposer les deux les deux clichés
parce que c'est exactement au même
endroit qu'elles sont prises à deux
années d'intervalle les nazis ont occupé
véritablement les champs elysées puisque
ils ont en fait réquisitionner à peu
près tous les immeubles et les cinémas
le cinéma il fait que pour lui à la
solde athènes qui n'ose les cinémas pour
heures les soldats allemands certains
voient la brasserie du fouquet's par
exemple dont on parlait en introduction
de cette discussion en fait elle est
aussi réquisitionné un très large partie
par les allemands et puis par l'allée
les dîners mondains de ses
collaborateurs s'est offert une
démonstration de force qu'on fait sur
les champs-elysées s'alimenter et c'est
ce que feront les jets les jaunes de la
même manière c'est une démonstration de
force
oui c'est ça c'est à dire qu'en fait il
ya une telle exhibition de pouvoir à la
fois économiques et politiques que
prendre la rue fin quand la voilà la rue
s'exprime aussi d'un point de vue
politique c'est intéressant que c'est
soit la cible encore une fois c'est pour
répondre à l'injonction sans doute
malheureuse et maladroite emmanuel
macron qu'il vienne me chercher
mais c'est aussi se dire que c'est là
que se trouve véritablement le un
concentré d'une richesse pelle
voilà j'ai travaillé par exemple sur les
palaces des champs elysées mais surtout
en réfléchissant aux conditions de
travail dans ces palaces en interrogeant
les grooms les concierges les portiers
les femmes de chambre
et donc voilà ce sont des palaces où la
chambre la suite coûte entre 15000 et
25000 euros la nuit et donc il ya cette
voix là ce contraste incroyable des
conditions de travail tellement
spécifiques et ce qui m'a passionné
c'est entendre des justement des femmes
de chambre de ces palaces ou des
barrières de chantier deere mais on et
gilet jaune on comprend les gilet jaune
quand à 100 mètres d'intervalle il ya un
client qui va s'acheter une bentley
qu'on sache et très un croissant ou un
pain au chocolat
et puis de l'autre des intérimaires des
chômeurs des questions des questions à
des infirmières voilà qui son gilet
jaune et qui se retrouve sur cette
avenue alors c'est aussi un lieu de fête
depuis toujours les champs-elysées il ya
des balles il ya des guinguettes
on les voit là il ya toujours eu des
fêtes aux champs elysées c'est sous
louis-philippe qu'on va chasser
finalement les dernières barak et il est
d'ailleurs au moment de la révolution de
48 quand on renverse mais philippe ça se
passe aussi bon quand même chose là en
effet le gouvernement provisoire de la
république tout juste proclamée en
février 1848 montrent justement une
estrade aux champs elysées pour
proclamer les principes républicains
mais en fait le pouvoir n'a eu de cesse
de justement de traquer et de vouloir
chasser le populaire et d'en faire une
avenue de prestige comme à la scène 1880
c'est devenu une avenue prestige du
processus d'organisation qui est aussi
une manière de mobiliser le capital en
acte 1 c'est là que vraiment la logique
capitaliste s'incarne véritablement
prend 1 prend ses quartiers suisse et
également avec louis napoléon bonaparte
quand il est élu en 48 président de la
république qui s'installait à l'elysée
tout une maison famille pour lui c'est
le napoléon y avait habité joséphine de
beauharnais aussi c'est l'elysée
napoléon comme l'appelle d'apollonia
quand l'appel à l'époque et on l'oubli
parce que mais il est en partie sur les
champs-elysées a eu des visées la grande
grille du jardin ça donne sur les champs
elysées
quand on est sur les champs elysées on
est sous les fenêtres quasiment de
l'elysée
c'est sous deux semaines dites vous donc
soumis naples et mambé enfin sous
napoléon iii une fois devenu empereur
que ça devient véritablement un lieu
mondain
c'est sur les champs elysées qu'on voit
là c'est haussmann en fait qui en a fait
ce qu ils sont tout à fait avec cette
perspective très austère oulaya il ya
d'autres types de conflits où il s'agit
à la fin de se demander quelle quelle
est la place réservée à la circulation
donc après c'est devenu aussi une
obsession d'urbanistes et de pouvoirs
publics et moi ça m'a intéressé de voir
les champs-elysées par exemple du point
de vue des cochers a décoché des coudes
et des gamins des rues qui déboussolé
janvier qu'on arrête sur les
champs-elysées la photographie là que
j'ai trouvé aux archives de paris
les petits gamins qu'on aime qu'on a
arrêté chirurgie la gabon des petits
d'aider des voleurs de deux boutons ou
de bonbons mais qui se sont envoyé en
maison de correction et certains même se
sont bâties à peu près à cette époque
dans les années 1880 une cabane
dans les jardins des champs-elysées donc
un contraste avec l'enfance de marcel
proust hôtel qui la relate dans à la
recherche du temps perdu puisque c'est
aussi là qu'il fait un peu son
apprentissage à tous égards mais rien à
voir avec ses enfants
c'est justement intéressant c'est que
c'est une avenue où se côtoient des
représentants et représentantes de
classe sociale tellement éloigné donc il
ya une sorte de cohabitation mais qui
qui est aussi conflictuelle et
finalement pas véritablement de
rencontres autres l on a beaucoup de
brisé deux vitrines sur les champs
elysées il ya eu d'autres manifestations
il ya eu des défilés du front populaire
il ya eu des attentats dans les années
70 beaucoup d'attentats sur les champs
elysées il ya le défilé de jouer là on
voit une manifestation grévistes sur les
champs-elysées en 36 léger les jaunes ce
n'était pas une première il ya toujours
eu cette tentation de venir il ya le
défilé de jean-paul goude en 1989 le
débit sans terre dans la révolution
c'est sur les champs elysées iliad ayant
un char russe qui paraît c'est jacques
attali qui comme on avait tellement dit
qu'ils auraient les chars russes sur les
champs-elysées si la gauche passe et au
goût va il a mis à chars russes
la suite était vraiment pensé quand le
cnpa non j'étais parti à catane et oui
oui oui il ya la coupe du monde de
football en 98 quand la france
l'emportent tout là toute la
la foule et sur les champs elysées quand
et c'est l'union sacrée à ce moment là
vous le dites on est tout le monde qui
vient sur les champs elysées pour une
victoire en coupe du monde c'est mignon
sacré allawi c'est qu'il ya deux aspects
ya d'abord la construction d'une forme
de sacralisation en effet de cet espace
qui commence véritablement en 1919 avec
1919-1920 donc la flamme du soldat
inconnu bien évidemment etc et puis donc
les défilés militaires et les hommages
rendus aux gloires nationales c'est
aussi la raison pour laquelle j'avais
été un peu perturbée par au moment de
l'acte des actes premier 8 décembre
lorsque ces sept entrées de certains
gilet jaune dans l'arc de triomphe et
les tags voilà c'est qu'on les riches
cet arc de triomphe un symbole de la
république parce que pour moi c'est
vraiment d'abord et avant tout un le
symbole d'un pouvoir impérial du pouvoir
royal de louis philippe qui a relancé la
construction labordère d'un bureau
depuis le long d'une voie là et puis
c'est justement le symbole de la guerre
en fait de la violence guerrière de la
violence militaire donc bon voilà qui
est réparé depuis
oui dans la la la et c'est vrai que là
comme shiden les jaunes on va on va les
voir maintenant là avec des images
maison lévis les jaunes c'est évidemment
si ce mouvement a fait le tour du monde
je parle le photographier bon parlons je
pense que c'est aussi lié au fait que ça
se passe sur les champs elysées ne
croyez vous pas mais c'est à dire qu'il
ya d'un côté donc cette sacralisation
qu'on évoquait un instant et de l'autre
cet espace de confrontation en effet un
qui n'est pas nouvelle puisque par
exemple sur le au moment du front
populaire
l'espace des champs elysées qui a
longtemps happart a pas retenu
finalement à la droite un au sens très
large du terme veut être ré approprier
par les forces du front populaire ce la
raison pour laquelle on manifeste aussi
à cet endroit et pas seulement sur les
trajectoires classique du mouvement
ouvrier bastille nation république
pendant la guerre d'algérie aussi bien
sûr il ya des manifestations dont la
manifestation du 17 octobre 1961 juin
nombre d'algériennes et d'algériens
trouvent la mort sous l'effet de la
répression on parle de peut-être 200 ou
300 morts au moment de cette répression
il y en a une partie qui changent
elysées absolument on va là et en mai
1968 au début du mouvement alors même
que c'est pas encore la grève générale
mais il ya une partie des étudiantes et
étudiants entre autres mais aussi des
jeunes ouvriers qui vont aller
manifester sur les champs elysées avant
dans les gaullistes le 30 mai avant que
le 30 mai soit une riposte
on entend non seulement vivent le
général mais aussi les cocos aux poteaux
il a une date importante c'est quand on
ouvre le rer que le erreur a organisé il
ya toute une partie de la banlieue s et
des banlieues populaires qui arrive
directement sur les changes et bien sûr
mais encore une fois ça s'inscrit
finalement dans un prolongement
historique le fait que cette avenue
elle est toujours été ce mélange où la
place du la place populaire en fait de
l'avenue qui se traduit d'ailleurs un
peu par le clivage entre les le côté des
numéros impairs ou là on trouve toutes
les boutiques de luxe et cetera et puis
de l'autre
justement les enseignes franchisées qui
se sont développées au prisme aussi de
l'arrivée de ces jeunes notamment d'une
phrase que vous citez d'ailleurs c'est
le commerce a tué l'élégance sur les
champs-elysées en croit que c'est
aujourd'hui qu'on dit chabanoise
commerce a que l'élégance en fait c'est
en 1925 on sait déjà en 1925 le commerce
est celle élégant oui oxfam et carmela
yard le comité qui à l'époque s'appelle
que le comité défense des champs-elysées
qui existe toujours des champs elysées
désormais ce n'est plus seulement de
défense mais se plaint dans les années
30 que telle boutique de prêt-à-porter
dans des robes trop peu cher qu'ils ne
sont pas
voilà à l'image du standing des
champions en fait la même si ça a été un
objet de conflit
et de savoir si c'était bien pour
l'image internationale des champs qui
est des mcdo et autres fnac
mais ce qui est intéressant encore une
fois c'est l'envers du décor c'est la
manière dont les gens vivent travaillent
sur sur cet espace là le fait qu'ils les
conditions de travail sont particulières
les il ya eu une bataille et des
batailles incessantes finalement sur
l'amplitude horaire en fait est ce que
est ce qu'il faut fermer les boutiques à
minuit à 2h du matin parce que ce sont
les champs elysées donc là il ya eu des
affrontements aussi important en terme
de condition sociale de travail sur
cette recette la plus belle avenue du
monde c'est signé ludivine bantigny ça
vient de paraître à la découverte ont
fait une pause et on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
l'arrivée de la série g est ce qu'on
peut parler de révolution
techniquement oui on peut parler de
révolution est ce qu'on pourrait pas
réservé sa à des applications bien
précise plutôt que vouloir absolument le
mettre à disposition tout le monde il
faut avoir en tête pour que pour chaque
génération il faut qu'elle soit
accompagnée dès qu'il est l'application
ça veut dire développer une application
qui fait le boom est ce que on a bien
mesuré toute la dépense énergétique de
nouveaux terminaux de nouvelle
implantation de relais le futur de la
cccd cdéc système de communication à
très très très haut débit soit enfin
télécharger un film plus vite
qu'est ce que ça va vous apporter les
craintes c'est parce qu'il ya un manque
d'information est probablement un nombre
de collaborations
est ce que aujourd'hui le monde entier a
besoin de la saint jean
[Musique]
je
le football est richissime et le
football génère beaucoup d'argent donc
génère beaucoup de redistribution pour
les footballeurs des principaux sportif
et donc leur rémunération
mais à côté tous les sportifs et
l'immense majorité des sportifs de haut
niveau qui participent aux jeux
olympiques et participe à des
championnats du monde gagne très mal
leurs vies ne sont absolument pas la
compagnie ne sont pas aidés ne sont pas
soutenues et résultats comme vous l'avez
dit 4 sur 10 gagnent moins de 500 euros
par mois donc je pense qu'il faudrait
réfléchir sur un dispositif vraiment
plus spécifique puisque le monde du
sport c'est une spécificité donc
peut-être tenté de rentrer de rentrer
dans sa pour pouvoir mieux accompagner
les sportifs de haut niveau est
considérée l'espoir un peu amateur comme
vous l'avez si bien dit à la téte isme
ou d'autres sports comme un métier on
parle de jeu pour le sport on parle de
loisirs de pratique de loisirs vraiment
d'amusement et de métier contraignant de
pénibilité pour le travail et ont donc
il serait logique d'accorder des aides
et des soutiens pour les travailleurs
est illogique de faire de même pour les
sportifs puisque il s'amuse
[Musique]
et
mes invités sont aujourd'hui ludivine
menti ni pour son livre la plus belle
avenue du monde kotil de bruno pour mal
tourné une bande dessinée sur une jeune
femme qui voit du sexe partout et elle
est assise man alegria qui publie son
second roman chez flammarion le grand
art dont le héros est un commissaire
priseur qui a connu son heure de gloire
mais désormais proche de la retraite est
un peu dépassé le métier a beaucoup
changé non commissaire priseur de ce
début de xxième siècle ça ne ressemble
pas au grand commissaire priseur de la
fin du xxème exactement c'est ce qui
arrive aux personnages paul vi viennent
c'est que il ne reconnaît plus son
propre métier parce que ça a tellement
changé en 10 15 ans avec l'arrivée
d'internet et des réseaux sociaux qu'il
est complètement largué et il n'arrive
pas à se réinventer alors il y en a qui
le font et lui il comprend pas les
enchères en ligne comprend pas que y'a
plus personne qui vient de conforter
campus désiré est payé très cher un
objet ou une oeuvre qu'on n'a pas vu en
vrai voilà ce qui arrive aujourd'hui est
ce que tu as complètement on connaissait
les enchères par téléphone ça a toujours
existé mais les gens venaient voir les
oeuvres sur place avant de il venait
avant et les regards des anonymes ou non
et puis après ils ont sécurisé par
téléphone mais non c'est vrai que le
commerce de l'art en ligne est en plein
en plein boom et que ce soit par les
réseaux sociaux ou par don au point
comme else's comme ça va oui c'est vrai
que alors on envoie bonne comme une
chappe priseur il commence ce roman en
train de lire le journal et lui ce qu'il
est évidemment c'est la rubrique
nécrologique
dès qu'il ya des seuils avant le
possible alors qu'est ce qu'il dit c'est
que pour lui son fond de commerce c'est
les 3 d les dettes le divorce et le
dessert
c'était en fait des cadettes des cas
divorce dès qu'il ya des seuils la
chance ou ya possibilité d'une à les
dépouiller un appartement lui l'appelle
sa dépouille et mais en réalité c'est
aussi le second vit enfin une nouvelle
vie tous ces objets ne sont pas nés dans
cette
dans cette famille là il existait avant
dans une autre famille dans une autre
maison et ils vont peut changer encore
une fois de maison de famille les objets
ne meurt pas en même temps que leurs
propres yvois la longueur beaucoup plus
longtemps que nous non mais c'est vrai
quand on y pense il donne beaucoup plus
réceptable il existera bien mais c'est
vrai il faut quand même le réaliser en
permanence les commissaires priseurs ils
savent ça nous sommes bien plus éphémère
que ça alors suite à un enterrement en
toscane alors c'est très drôle
d'ailleurs parce qu'il assistait à un
enterrement et leur laisse le petit
détail et au cours de cet enterrement et
ils voient que le moral et c'est une
très belle pendule bien mise en évidence
et en fait il s'aperçoit après que
c'était un coup de génie et c'est une
très belle pendule on se dit bon bah
donc il ya un héritage qui va être
formidable et en fait non il a mis là en
évidence qui avait de mieux pour un
attrape nigaud de hadath en commission
c'est un attrape que des surprises
oui comme ça au hasard ou bons mollets
il est mort donc on se dit que avant
quand il donnait des réceptions et ben
c'était un peu un objet éclatant pour en
mettre plein la vue et faire croire
qu'ils avaient les moyens d'avoir une
grande micro n'est derrière ou plein de
choses et effectivement mais en moins
dans cet héritage il va trouver un
mystérieux retable par un florentin
inconnu l'adaptation c'est début du
xvème siècle
mais ses antérieurs à la découverte à
l'invention de la perspective par bonnet
les skis on sait que bon élève qui a
inventé la perspective entre 415 et 425
le premier à l'avoir utilisé ces
masaccio qui était très jeune et là le
tableau serait antérieure en face d'un
retable ce serait antérieur et l'a su ce
serait dingue ça c'est une révolution ce
serait dingue pour ceux qui sont
vraiment tatillon sur la santé ce serait
d'ailleurs que disons assez pas de
grande révolution mais c'est vrai que ce
serait énorme
ça voudrait dire quelqu'un a fait un
tableau avec de la perspective avant
masaccio en occident oui oui mais on dit
que ça a été inventé par rené ce qui met
donc en dépression voilà on dit ça mais
en fait qu'est ce qu'on en sait pas ce
que c'est ce que j'explique dans le
roman brunious qui il a laissé aucun
écrit parce qu'il était très avare de
ses inventions et donc il avait très
peur de la concurrence y brûler tout est
donc on dit comme ça vasari un siècle
plus tard 10 et brunes et les skis qu'il
a inventés mais ça arrange bien
l'histoire d'ériger un peu voler ce
qu'est un héros en disant je suis en
train de remettre en question du tout
j'espère bien le génie brunet veste
juste que en fait on n'en sait rien oui
mais alors si vous aller jusque là le
tableau vous avez montré on l'a
attribuée à caravage mais avant cela on
l'avait attribué à quelqu'un d'autre ça
c'est mais ces voix là et c'est à peu
près le cas de la plupart des tableaux
de cette époque puisqu'ils ne sont pas
signés bien c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles des axes de votre robe seco
faut tout ça et tu d'histoire
d'attribution on attribue un tel c'est
exactement mon propos est ce qui m'a ce
qui m'a inspiré ou ce qui m'a ce qui a
nourri mon imaginaire c'est que quand on
voit la joconde on se dit ok on me dit
que c'est un que c'est léonard mais bon
ce panneau de bois de peuplier qui
auraient traversé les alpes à dos de
mulet il ya 500 ans
je suis pas sûr que ce soit exactement
cela et pas un autre c'est c'est juste
on le dit alors probablement mais c'est
aussi possible que non et sinon et bien
d'où il vient et quelle est son histoire
et c'est un peu sa vie face à ce retable
dont il ya votre commissaire priseur
il ya aussi une jeune experte en art qui
doivent à eau qui nous ressemblent un
peu d'ailleurs comme ça que je
l'imaginais maintenant je vous que je
vous connais elle aussi elle va se
demander qui est cette hauteur et là ça
devient une véritable enquête c'est à
dire que vous pouvez date est assez
précisément le bois et vous savez que
grosso modo c'est 14 105,14 115 on peut
penser avoir peint dessus c'est très
précis et vous commencez à regarder tous
les peintres alors elle elle dit au
coach après 60,1 très peu donc on va
regarder ceux qui sont nés ses vins
voilà l époque les plus de 60 ans non
c'est pas la peine donc on regarde tout
ce qu'ils ont pu peindre ça peut pas
être masaccio étaient trop jeunes des
terres aux ans et pas lui
donc on va chercher et elle commence à
chercher comment ça se fait il vient de
céder
maintenant c est évidemment et elle
trouve et et
et c'est ça qui est intéressant le
problème c'est que c'est plus à la mode
c'est à dire que tout à coup autour de
ce commissaire présent on se dit mais
attendez vendre un même un type qui
arrivent et le chiot nail art au début
du xvème siècle s'intéresse personne en
ce moment ils s'intéressent plus à des
planches de bandes dessinées ces
nouveaux collectionneurs les nouveaux
collectionneurs ils connaissent pas la
peinture ils se sont démultipliés mais
ils connaissent pas la peinture
il s'intéresse à la bande dessinée donc
une planches originales d'hergé ça c'est
bon éventuellement des photos ça ils
comprennent mais à retable du xvème
siècle encore une fois pour viviane et
est un peu à côté de la plaque
c'est beau trop héros les îles et il est
encore une fois papa en phase avec son
temps et avec son époque parce que pour
lui
ben il est venu il a une épiphanie
devant cette oeuvre
et il veut prouver à tout le monde que
qu'il réussira à faire grimper la cote
d'un retable du quattrocento dont
effectivement plus personne s'intéresse
plus personne et c'est ça qui veut faire
et pour lui ça devient vraiment je vis
là il a beau d'exemple ya le fameux
salvator mundi de léonard de vinci qui a
été vendu 450 millions de dollars chez
christie's
alors qu'il est hideuse on peut le dire
je veux même pas gelé mais j'ai même pas
vu le trou vidéo y compris dans votre
roman de 32 ans avait dans men et je
vais vu en vrai il n'ya pas très
longtemps au louvre à l'exposition l'ena
il est absolument horrible et vous
expliquer d'ailleurs en tout cas un
nouveau personnage explique dans ce
monde ci s'est vendu si fier parce
qu'ils ont mis dans une vente d'art
contemporain 10 ans nés entre bastia et
louise bourgeois et y et puis comme il
était tellement repeint des ciels fina
me ressemble à un truc d'art
contemporain et puis léonard de vinci
c'est quand même le seul peintre qui
trouve grâce aux yeux de
du monde aujourd'hui puisque c'est le
seul nom qu'on a retenue c'était parce
que tout le monde a oublié puis rod le
premier s'intéresse plus trop alors que
léonard c'est le pain de des peintres
c'est le biopic avec dicaprio qui va
peut-être sortir un jour vous trouvez
pas qu'il est un peu surestimé le nom de
vinci soyez honnête j'aime beaucoup ses
carnets j'ai vu les faits ce que tout le
monde l'aimé tout le monde des carnets
l'époque oui c'est maintenant il y avait
des trucs en fait non non j'ai quand
même beaucoup d'affection pour lui papa
pour le salvator mundi mais pour eux
mêmes des les machines en général mais
ils n'ont pas marché ne marchait pas les
machines non non mais mais il ya plein
d'offres qui est quand même le jean
baptiste il est très très beau oui
évidemment il ya des des très très beau
c'est sûr et mais alors ce qui est drôle
c'est que là on voit comment on peut
faire naître un peintre caravage on l'a
fait naître de la même manière à un
moment un grand historien italien a fait
naître caravage 400 ans après sa mort
hélas ses 500 ans après la mort de ce
peintre inconnu
on peut le faire naître tout à coup et
là on se sert des réseaux sociaux et les
réseaux sociaux vont jouer un rôle dans
votre roman va pas dévoiler tout ce qui
se passe mais mais voilà on assiste à la
naissance d'un peintre et tout le monde
le monde entier commence à se passionner
pour ce peintre que personne ne
connaissait trois semaines avant
personne n'avait jamais eu connaissance
et évidemment aussi bien le commissaire
priseur que votre jeune experte en art
deviennent des stars parce que ils ont
découvert a pas trop de j'ai dit voilà
c'est exactement ça mais je pense que ça
peut aider
caravage ces salons du 20e siècle et ça
peut arriver de demain puisque il ya des
peintres des primitifs italiens
totalement inconnu méconnu il suffit
tout à coup d'en trouver 3 ou 4 ou
d'avoir une bonne idée et est exposé aux
socios et on se dit que ça pourrait
marcher mais c'est ça qui m'a intéressé
c'est c'est raconter comment on fabrique
un mythe dans enfin turcomans un tableau
devient un tableau de musées que tout le
monde a envie de photographier d'aller
voir qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'un tableau
raconte en dehors du fait qu'il soit bon
c'est vrai pour les paysages aussi il ya
des paysages qui tout à coup apparaît
sur instagram et
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent attirent des milliers des
dizaines de milliers de gens à tel point
qu'on oblige les fermes de fermer
l'endroit pour que les gens arrêtent de
le saccager
au fond on fait naître des peintres
comme on fait naître des paysages qui
ont toujours existé mais tout à coup ils
sont sur instagram c'est plus tout à
fait la même chose et il ya tout le truc
aussi du peintre maudit et ça attire
beaucoup les gens forcément ma le
caravage toute son histoire ça participe
de sa légende et de la mythification
c'est à dire quand on retrouve des des
moments de sa vie qui font que on a
envie d'en savoir plus il est mystérieux
il est
c'est dans le cadre caravage c'est
particulier lui comme il a été condamné
à mort il est tous les jours mais van
gogh peintre maudit enfin ce genre
pareil ça marche très bien il ya une
morale dans votre livre
quelqu'un dit plus on dénonce plus vous
m puis vous à bâle et qui ici d'ailleurs
aussi bien marcel duchamp que que bansky
et banque sib plus on dénonce plus vous
m puis vous avez oui bah ça c'était par
rapport à l'oeuvre de banksy qui s'est
vendue aux enchères en fait tu irais je
sais pas si vous avez suivi il ya une
oeuvre qu'on a achetée aux enchères et
puis en fait il y avait une machine à
découper le papier à l'intérieur et
s'est autodétruite voilà c'est un coup
de com mais est en même temps c'est
aussi une dénonciation de l'absurdité du
de l'enchère et on se dit c'est morceau
de papier et phare sur le sol va demain
ils vendront 3 pas pu faire que l'oeuvre
originale parce que tu as dit barcella
marchand c'est la même chose il ya
beaucoup d'ironie critique du système au
départ en tout cas serrée de l'iemed le
système là avait la veille
il veut devenir un objet de musée avec
une barrière autour alors sautière quoi
le roman s'appelle le grand art il est
signé les à simone et alegria et il est
paru chez flammarion
[Musique]
qu'at-il bruno vous êtes là sedaris de
mal tourner un album avec des dessins
disait python qui vient de paraître chez
porn pop
c'est l'histoire d'une jeune femme qui
voit du sexe partout comment vous est
venue une histoire passée assez simple
quand j'ai commencé à écrire avant même
de 12 mètres j'avais déjà ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais envie de faire du
plan d'eau oui l'idée me faisait rire en
fait il y avait un peu de la bravade là
dedans de dire tiens pourquoi pas ça
doit être rigolo puissant un exercice de
style et plus je me suis mise plus je me
suis dit bon cas il faut que je trouve
quelque chose mais l'idée c'est
évidemment de faire quelque chose qui me
ressemble quand même un petit peu et
finalement le juge la chose la plus
simple c'est de se dire mais qu'est ce
qui me caractérise moi moi je trouve que
j'ai effectivement l'esprit assez mal
tourné et en fait c'est très simple elle
écrit il suffit de prendre une idée et
de l'art en un peu extrême de l'outré et
retrouver une fille qui veulent dessine
c'est sa plus difficile c'est sacrément
fait et d'écrire l'histoire et du coup
bas à partir du moment où j'ai cette
idée là en me disant bon bah on va
prendre un prétexte très simple de
lendemains de soirées un petit peu trop
de drogues etc puis hop ça suffira le
pondérer vraiment du sexe partout c'est
à dire que dans la rue comme on va le
voir
tout à coup les arbres se transforme en
phallus mai mais je crois que tout le
monde était comme ça moi moi si on est
apte et de soldats dans cette pièce
disons que le problème pour daphné pour
cette journée un peu particulière
qu'elle va passer c'est que en plus
d'avoir donc l'esprit mal tourné de mal
interpréter les choses les choses se
matérialisent vraiment à tel point
qu'elle un petit peu du mal à discerner
la réalité de sa propre fiction de son
propre fantasme
ce qui fait que bon dans la rue ça
devient compliqué mais en réunion de
travail encore plus dans un bus avec des
grands-mères étouffant chaque situation
en fête prend une ampleur
disproportionnée alors c'est marrant
parce qu'on pense évidemment aux livres
célébrissime de milo manara le déclic
mais c'est une version féminine
dans dans le déclic elle ne pouvait pas
s'empêcher de faire alors que dans votre
album à vous elle ne peut pas s'empêcher
elle se contente plus exactement dit
penser là ne fait rien alors elle ne
fait rien justement c'est un peu c'est
très féminin alors s'est alors fait non
je ne sais pas en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que c'est une reprise de
pouvoir peut-être parce que là la femme
n'est pas l'objet enfin elle subit
certes un petit peu cette situation mais
c'est mine de rien elle qui à certains
moments décide de ce qu'elle va faire de
qui elle va aller voir dans les deux
gars qui jouaient sur ac ça exactement
là c'est non elle subit parce qu'il ya
eu trop gay mais à part ça c'est elle
qui décide de se rendre dans certains
endroits d'essayer de se masturber un
moment bon même s'il est un peu
interrompu en cours de route et
finalement c'est une vraie reprise de
pouvoir sur ses fantasmes et c'est
d'ailleurs ce hack interroge le bouquin
si au début c'est plutôt un aspect un
peu rigolo parce qu'en effet se
retrouvent dans des situations
incongrues
après on est peut-être un peu elle
cherche un petit peu a testé sa et
d'aller plusieurs l'excitation
la troisième partie du bouquin devient
un peu oppressante parce qu'elles
contrôlent plus rien que ya un moment où
bon bah oui ça devient trop en fait la
maîtrise plus du tout mais finalement il
s'agit de ça 2 comment est-ce qu'on gère
son propre fantasme et son propre corps
vis-à-vis de ça alors c'est vrai que
c'est dans une soirée qu'on lui a donné
une pilule c'est ça qui lui a fait cet
effet c'est ça c'est un petit peu en
tout cas ce qu'on suggère valeur parce
que on se dit on est dans une époque où
évidemment tout est très très sexuée
enfin un petit peu moins ces derniers
temps ça
si la pression mais c'était alors on va
en fait de tout cela je pense que tout
est très sexuée tout le temps enfin dans
notre esprit pas forcément de manière
négative d'ailleurs mais enfin en tout
cas ça le juste mon esprit qui est donc
très mal tourner mais j'ai le sentiment
qu'on peut très vite tout interpréter si
on passait filtre là
c'est temps mais oui on est dans une
époque où anglais publicité la
télévision où il ne s'engagera très
explicite la question c'est que du coup
de voir ce qu'on fait de ces stimuli là
et de comment on raconte une histoire
autour de ça mais là que je me suis
posée est ce qu'il ya vraiment des
extras qui font cet effet là alors j'en
ai marre de tester verser des amendes
ipupa ce qu'ils regardent une fille dans
la rue qu'ils soient qui se caressent la
nuque pauvres voilà ce qu'elle voit et
je me suis dit est ce qu'il ya des extra
qui font ça alors par la connaissance
peut-être que ça existe il faudrait
mener une enquête en quelques poussées
sur le sujet c'est mon postulat disant
que c'est là la grosse part de fiction
du bouquin c'est effectivement cette
espèce de drogue magique qui produit des
effets secondaires jusqu'au lendemain
vrai mais pour l'instant il rendez vous
est venu comment vraiment juste en me
disant bon ben ok qu'est ce que quel
concept narratif on peut utiliser sur
cette thématique de caisse
qu'est-ce qui se passe si on prend voilà
ce titre qui peuvent caractériser
d'avoir l'esprit mal tourné si on en
fait quelque chose narrativement au
niveau de la fiction comment comment
comme on le tourne et du coup est arrivé
assez vite j'ai proposé l'idée à mon
éditeur et finalement comme je le disais
tout à l'heure c'est peut-être quasiment
plus de trouver quelqu'un avec qui
travailler
finalement je me suis rappelé de dessins
qui avaient pu faire risa sur des
projets différents 3e gardien carl
hozjan coach qui est celle qui colorise
là je voulais dit je me suis dit c'est à
la fois une métaphore de notre époque
qui est totalement pornographiques mais
je me suis aussi c'est peut être l'idée
qu'elles se font qu'elle se fait de ce
qui se passe dans la tête d'un homme
dont la réputation d'être très obsédé et
j'ai aussi dit au fond peut-être que ces
financements se défend pas trop mal
aussi à mon avis c'est plutôt équivalent
très clairement
mais non je pense qu'à mon avis c'est ce
qui se passe dans sa propre tête mais
alors ce qui m'intéresse plus quasiment
plus que cette comparaison là parce que
je pense qu'à mon avis c'est pareil
c'est vraiment pareil c'est plus en fait
ce qu'elle découvre dans son propre
esprit parce qu'en fait jusqu'à leur
redoute quand même des tabous une école
primaire elle se dit non dans là il faut
pas qu'elle reste elle risque d'avoir là
aussi csle et c'est justement tout
l'idée de du fantasme et dans ce qu'on a
dans le fond du crâne est effectivement
de comptia incontrôlable donc oui
évidemment il ya les tabous qu'on a
vis-à-vis de nous-mêmes iasci résoudre
de manière incontrôlée dans le fond de
notre cerveau et qui se met à sortir
tout à coup comme ça et c'est plutôt ça
qu'interroge de livres et alors ce qui
est drôle c'est qu'elle est assailli par
les fantasmes mais elles ne violent
personnes non elle harcèle un peu mais
elle viole pas sans trop s'en rendre
compte comme elle maîtrise plus trop en
fait la réalité les objets qu'il y ait
ou pas non parce que c'est vraiment
quelque chose finalement c'est très
centrée sur elle et sur son propre désir
d'ailleurs à la fin il ya quelque chose
de très légèrement filet pendant tous
les livres que vous voilà elle a
quelques uns qui lui envoient des
messages avec qui on sent qu en fait il
se passe peut être un truc mais voilà
yellow ce pas trop envoyer des messages
parce qu'à desquels temps de le faire il
ya des emoji qui se met à faire
n'importe quoi justement et à forniquer
sur son écran dans quelle panique un
petit buzz mais il ya cette espèce de
truc un peu filer qu'il arrive jusqu'à
la fin mais on voit même si oui elle va
peut-être enfin réussir à aller prendre
un verre avec cette personne qui l
intéresse
en fait elle va surtout de cette enfin
réussir à avoir un orgasme
parce que finalement pendant tout le
livre elle ne fait que voir des choses
qui peuvent vous balle à stimuler et
qu'ils font appel à ce désir là mais
sans pouvoir jamais finalement aller au
bout et une pornographie film féminine
du cioc la pornographie est typiquement
masculine elle s'adresse aux hommes et
même les femmes quand elles font de la
pornographie on ré tendance dit on à
avoir parlé aux jeunes
cc c'est assez compliqué moi j'ai un peu
recherché d'abord en tant que
consommatrice si je puis dire mais aussi
pendant le pendant le l'écriture il ya
je crois que marc dorcel essayer de
faire un site vaguement pour les femmes
etc
mais généralement
des réalisatrices de faire des biens sur
des vraies réalisatrice power exactement
il ya eu plusieurs il y avait plusieurs
films alors on voit qui a d'anciennes
porn stars qui parfois justement vont
traiter je pense à ovidie notamment mais
qui vont traiter de ce sujet là c'est
souvent à ses militants après un produit
purement pornographiques adressé aux
femmes chez l'impression qu'on n'a pas
vraiment trouvé de quelque chose de
formule magique en quelque sorte je sais
qu'il y avait eu aussi une série de
courts métrages sur dvd en tout qui
s'appelait dirty diaries qui a dû sortir
une petite dizaine d'années quelque
chose comme ça mais dans les
réalisatrices y avait beaucoup d'
artiste plasticienne
il y avait beaucoup en fait deux
militantes aussi donc c'était un objet
qui fonctionnait pour de la pornographie
féminine mais que c'était quasiment plus
un discours sur la pornographie féminine
que en soi un film adressé aux femmes de
manière basique si je puis dire qui va
être belle allez-y masturber vous en
regardant ça et c'est vrai que
iliad est parfois un peu de pistes du
côté du japon parce que le hentai est
très riche dans toute sa variété parce
que c'est le même pardon le ventech chez
le porno japonais en dessin animé ou en
manga donc dessiné et tout comme le
manga extrêmement riche dans tous ces
sujets on va parler de du chip pas de
quelqu'un qui veut dédier sa vie au pain
comme de basket comme de n'importe quoi
la même manière le porno japonais un peu
iatria un peu tout il est très connu
pour ses monstres poulpe
voilà à tentacules parti clairement ça
c'est assez féminin ça c'est finalement
alors c'est toujours assez souvent vu du
point de vue de l'homme parce que le nda
effectivement il ya quand même beaucoup
de scènes de violence notamment avec ces
monstres tentacules ce qu'ont fait un
petit peu différemment nous dans mal
tourné parce que ça peut aussi au
contraire être quelque chose de
stimulant pour des femmes mais voilà en
tout cas personnellement j'ai plus
trouver des choses qui m'intéressait
dans de la fiction que dans quelque
chose de volontairement fin 2-2
pornographique de qui va être postées
sur paname portneuf vous ou sur d'autres
plateformes je sais que pendant
l'écriture j'ai regardé shortbus
beaucoup que j'avais vu pas mal d'années
en avant qui a un film qui doit dater de
2000 début des années 2000 où il ya pas
mal de sexe non simulées mais qui a été
fait avec vous pensez à un point de vue
j'ai pas si c'est extrêmement militants
mais en tout cas tant des communautés in
new yorkaise où les voilà il ya des
scènes d'orgies mais assez bienveillante
et cetera il ya c'est l'histoire d'une
femme qui est sexologue mais qui n'a
jamais réussi à avoir un orgasme et qui
donc va suivre un couple d'amis à elle
qu'il emmène un petit peu dans divers
soirée et tous ces traits féminins dans
le truck masculin l'orgasme tout le
porte ses fruits va voler mais l'a dit
qu on est en tout cas on suit en place
et surtout ça s'est construit un
personnage féminin pardon dont le but
est finalement d'accéder enfin au
plaisir et disons que souvent le porno
qui à destination des hommes
la question de la jouissance féminine
est pas vraiment mise au premier plan
très clairement non les entends crier
tout haut oui bah oui alors il protesté
après ça ne veut pas dire qu'il a quand
même
un petit signe anna disent que c'est de
la pornographie faites par des femmes et
il est présent d'ailleurs dans votre
album c'est qu'il ya des hommes entre
eux
oui et ça vous n'en verrez que dans
l'époque mais pas des femmes les
feuilles les pornos fait perdre et on
verra déjà mais deux hommes en train de
copuler vous ne savez rien prédation
celle ci y en a c'est que c'est fait par
des fans là d'ailleurs et la beaujoire
joint en tout cas c'est et c'est encore
quelque chose contre beaucoup au japon
il ya un type de hentai alors c'est pas
tout à fait du même taille mais un type
de bd qui s'appelle le yaoi et qui parle
de pornographie homosexuelle masculine
et c'est très drôle parce que toute
cette partie là de la pornographie
japonaise et ses 90 % de femmes qui le
dessiner que je l'écrive alors que
finalement ça parle de deux hommes entre
eux il ya vraiment une des communautés
très très investis émotionnellement au
niveau des fenêtres ou dans ce type
d'histoire et c'est drôle parce qu en
effet finalement ça regroupe des
communautés pas uniquement mais en tout
cas dans les créatrices vraiment enfin
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de femmes y à de
la pornographie féminine que vous avez
remarqué dans l'art aujourd'hui de la
pornographie féminine
non je sais que j'avais trouvé un site à
un moment de pornographique était
adressée aux femmes et je voulais voir
ce que ça donnait parce que ça
m'intéresse beaucoup
mais mais c'était payant mais bien que
sur des trucs astuces amérique-là parce
que pourquoi la mère de greef masculine
y en a partout on assuré dé confié que
c'était gratuit on a beaucoup trop et
pour les femmes il faut payer
on est bien d'accord de divine continue
la transition avec les chances je dis en
1975 le x enfin avant que la loi sur le
x et quand on est libéral à nice la
pornographie tous les cinémas des champs
elysées dire il est en tout cas moi je
m'inscrirai volontiers dans l'idée d'une
pornographie non sexiste et émancipée
justement des contraintes de pression
que quelqu'un suivi pour beaucoup voilà
je vous remercie tout les trois devoir
participer à cette émission mais elle
tournait sur un scénario de je parle pas
de l'émission je m'habille belle tournée
scénario de type 2
bruno dessin 10 à piton c'est pas un
pseudo il à piton pour les avions c'est
son vrai nom n'a gardé maintenant mise
en couleur scarlett spirkovski ça vient
de paraître chez pol pop la plus belle
avenue du monde l'essai de ludivine
bantigny c'est à la découverte et le
grand art le roman de l'est à simone
alegria c'est chez flammarion merci de
nous avoir suivis rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]